this is all my fault
i can't save everyone
look around you
this is what we do
we help people
exclusively in cinemas coming soon
can we just like stay up here all day it
is so crazy down there
spiderman is in fact peter parker
so peter do what do i owe the pleasure
when mysterio revealed my identity my
entire life got screwed up this is
hurting a lot of people i was wondering
if maybe you could make it so that he
never did
the entire world is about to forget that
peter parker is spider-man wait everyone
m.j ned man may should really stop
tampering with the spell
what just happened
multiverse is a concept about which we
know frighteningly little
be careful what you wish for a partner
hello peter
[Music]
you ready
i know this is my message
and i swear to you that i'll fix it
but i'm gonna need some help i can't
believe i'm in the sanctum i'm saying
it's horum neither can i exclusively in
movie theaters thursday
truth is i accidentally brought those
dangerous people here
the world if you're watching wish me
luck
friendly neighborhood spider-man can
really use something
exclusively at movie theaters thursday
next time you break the universe
maybe just run it by us deal exclusively
in movie theaters
all right parker
you ready
world if you're watching
wish me luck
exclusively in cinemas coming soon
you